according I do these things now and I
know brighter side we're just gonna show
me make it cool you're supposed to make
it cool I'm supposed to come up you're
not supposed to show me going down god
dammit
oh what's that oh I'm wearing a hot new
merch culturally cultural appropriating
are we Felix that's right yeah
luckily YouTube doesn't a Russian yet so
we're fine with this mean check out the
marsh link in the description limited
time availability Oh
Oh Oh No Oh what did he do yes that's
right everybody I went to the
hairdresser and I said hey man hit me up
with a suck hair that's how I'm
committed to the memes
okay I'm not some bullsh me Mert this is
serious
for extra slub pull up my chain look how
cool this Marches is guys check out link
in the description if you're a real suka
just do it roll the intro in case we
haven't already
leave your but can a reptilian do this
it annoys me a little bit the fact that
he's just become a reptilian when
clearly he's an Android
perhaps an Android reptilian if finding
nemo had been scientifically accurate
Nemo's dad would have switched sexes
after Nemo's mom died and made with
it's got 2000 up boats on the Peter pine
subreddit congratulations everyone
you're a bunch of scumbags you're a
bunch of weirdo scumbags congratulations
everyone the bad news is that he won't
get another Boehner's mean for at least
a month
you're welcome everyone I'm still
smiling this whole week remembering it
was a bonus meme this week why are you
so happy well the united state
government lecturing mark zuckerberg
about invading people's practice I don't
know if you guys have seen the cringing
moments of that I wish I highlighted
them better but it's pretty bad there's
a lot of good stuff from that hashtag
pay brad bonus me twisty affect
everybody all means aside I I don't
think I would thank bright enough i he's
been working with me for five years it's
been that long
goddamn yeah and he really pulled my
channel out of the rich cringy dark hole
that he was spiraling down into so
everyone hashtag thanks Brad click here
if you want to cry sponsor eagle oh can
we just let means die do we have to keep
bringing them up by the way guys I don't
know if you heard about this new
campaign Kony 2012 it's really important
cost that I think if we all just get
together and support we can finally
defeat this evil man
damnit
you know how close I am to starting a
patreon just so now how to deal with all
this I'm not gonna okay I can't even
look at myself I look so weird who is
this guy if the be in LGBT stands for
bisexual doesn't that mean that there
are only two Italian I can confirm my
sadness is all the time who is they
I feel like I recognize it it looks like
some weird Jerry Seinfeld hybrid it's
disturbing okay I don't want to see it
but who hunts the bully hunters also
congratulations guys
the website is down forever well done
I'm proud of you guys I'm proud aren't
bonus meme just normal memes but with
peers yelling bonus mean before them are
you in stupid that's ridiculous
are you kidding me that's the most foul
thing I ever heard you know what you're
perma banned spicy yams how do I ban I
forget makes Americans look bad
well that's true makes British people
look bad makes lizard people look bad oh
there's poor lizard people makes Swedish
people look under it I'll take it you
know what fine how to give a manly
handshake oh like I don't need to I
don't need to know this get out of the
mud
get out of my toes wait so do you think
pude should add bonus news to pew news
that's this is ridiculous news is a very
serious news website we don't we don't
do with memes okay please don't make me
laugh
mace the breed team any means B became
gg I kept thinking why are they so many
brand memes and then I realized I think
I said it in the last video tonight next
one we're gonna have it a little themed
around Brad and and Brad to subscribers
hate him he managed to pick us up
what is this I kind of want to click hi
everybody it's me Brad water from the
PewDiePie channel you can follow me on
Twitch at
TV slash brat worth touch when you're at
a zoo and see a lizard oh hi mark
uber driver oops wrong turn youtuber I
was almost kidnapped story time I mean
this is just fact if you watch any one
of those videos
he took me like them slightly longer
route and I thought I was going to get
you are just full of pills what am I
supposed to say
I need substitute words or something
this is oh my god this is already so
accurate you use copyrighted material
again that's the only way to make your
videos funny but that's why I get
demonic taste you don't pay me anyway so
I can't even afford your stupid chick
bride to was my favorite brand all along
this is honestly the most accurate meme
I've ever seen sigh will at least make
sure the video isn't could be monetized
if the video is to monetize Brad is
literally just like I I guess that's how
it is have I told you about my suka yeah
merch by the way pretty cool it means
good friend and Swahili this is my most
lava moment of this channel I have
decided to shut down drama learn as I
have reasonably discovered it isn't fair
to Pew News I now hand the news to you
PewDiePie
well this has just been fact all along
plus I'm not the one doing the news you
did silly no it's Gloria Borger
ever wonder why he's big doesn't use
cabbage because he's a robot
lizard this is how good memes die
because you guys can't figure out what
the what the meme is you keep changing
them like they have to have no value if
you don't treat it like it doesn't have
any value then it doesn't get any
respect the means and you get that
respect back
[Music]
that is so cool
I love it Sam Jones art that is so dope
some of the world's greatest thinkers
that's try to do that bread one and
bread to the wise submissions that's
right to get on the wire you really got
a mooch up with Brad one and Brad - it's
not me okay
I'm not the one in control of this just
like I'm not in control of Bowness me
hey my Russian friend did this art did
you know you have a big community in
Russia it's time to put your wallet or
your mouth fish okay that's really cool
art by the way I would really love it
everyone says that name you broke a
record by gaining 1 million subscribers
in nine days but they first actually
forgot about the legend by getting 1
million subscribers in just a few hours
it's okay don't worry guys I'm
completely used to my achievements and
goals completely getting crushed by
everyone else it's normal you know I'm a
humble man I don't need to brag about
these things every day spent on this
subreddit is a privilege oh my god
[Music]
yeah back good job
I'm glad glad you spend a lot of time
making that nice one well done now this
is an accurate read by the way it's
pretty cool let's start with the hair
I'm going to the fulfilling prophecy my
drawing of suck his true identity oh my
god lizard Android lizard Android if you
don't draw him with at least one red eye
that goes up but then I don't care okay
don't waste my time with this oh my god
oh my god I'm so proud of you
is it supposed to be like Iron Man
reference yeah that's funny this was a
top mean by far
congratulations everyone that's it for
this week's of love ye link merch and a
description copied now while you can
it's only available limited availability
thank you guys so much for all the memes
I mean you're welcome for the memes and
I'll see you guys next time
[Music]